hi I'm Erik Bosse in Star Wars Episode
nine as thus far been kept under a
pretty tight lid by director JJ Abrams
but a new leaked scene description has
surfaced that suggests the final chapter
this new trilogy might bring back some
of the visuals and elements that fans
have loved about the franchise and I'm
sure it will appease everyone in a
spoiler warning the case you don't want
to know anything about the future of
Star Wars Episode nights release date is
until December 2019 so we got to fill
this time with something okay according
to reports from episode 9 set at
Pinewood Studios in England one scene
being shot for the film will feature
kylo Ren witnessing his grandfather
Anakin Skywalker in some kind of
flashback force dream joing the moment
Anakin was reconstructed into the form
of Darth Vader at the end of Revenge of
the Sith
here's the description kylo Ren inside a
medical room he is walking down a
hallway when he hears someone screaming
and pain he walks into another room
where he discovers Anakin Skywalker
Darth Vader with a suit on but his mask
off
pinned to a wall where heavy machinery
is replacing his old mechanical legs and
arms with new ones then walks closer to
the Darth Vader figure in pain and
examines his burns before a piece of
machinery swings behind kylo that
eventually puts on the mask of Darth
Vader kylo Ren turns around and exits
the room and wakes up from his sleep in
his chambers almost mirroring the
nightmare Anakin had in Revenge of the
Sith so essentially what we're talking
about is a restaging of the moment at
the end of episode 3 when Anakin
mutilated and left for dead after his
duel with obi-wan on Mustafar hid
surgically reassembled on course on by
Palpatine's medical droids it's a pretty
gross scene and really one of the better
moments of the film the idea that JJ
Abrams wants to resample it shows that
the director still has that pretty good
understanding of what elements or past
Star Wars movies are worth revisiting
pretty excited to see what Industrial
Light and Magic is able to pull off with
their old footage
considering the magic they were able to
pull off with Carrie Fisher and rogue
one and what visual effects movies like
ready player one have accomplished
restaging footage from The Shining it's
interesting that this description
compared this moment to Anakin's
nightmares and Revenge of the Sith if
you recall Annie yeah I remember I was
called Annie had nightmares about Padme
dying childbirth
calling out for him to help which ended
up being kind of a self-fulfilling
prophecy when Padme later did die in
childbirth
arguably due to the trauma to Anakin
getting too emo really to me this state
sounds more like a replay of Ray
for stream in the force awakens which
briefly transported raid to a mysterious
location that we later realized was the
same hallway of Cloud City from the
Empire Strikes Back actually concept art
and rejected alternate plants for this
scene we're going to have Ray directly
witnessed the duel between Luke
Skywalker and Darth Vader in that air
shaft
of course JJ Abrams final version of
that force dream and force awakens
wasn't that much of a direct call back
to the earlier films but with this new
scene description from episode 9 it
sounds like he may be reusing that kind
of idea with kylo as George Lucas says
it's like poetry it rhymes openly it'll
work the memory of Luke invadors epic
fighting Empire would have been meant to
connect to the history of the lightsaber
that Ray had just touched to evoke this
memory so perhaps kylo revisiting this
moment with Vader could have been
triggered by him finding something that
belonged to his grandfather he already
has his mask which chronologically first
entered the Star Wars saga at this
precise moment on the medical table or
perhaps kylo managed to recover his
grandfather's lightsaber which we last
saw falling down the same reactor shaft
that Vader threw Palpatine down at the
end of Return of the Jedi look guys if
Darth Maul can fall down a reactor shaft
and pop back up again in the future
movie sunken Vader's lightsaber and
maybe the thematic reason kylo is seeing
this moment is for him to witness the
pain both the physical torture and the
emotional turmoil that his grandfather
had to go through to let go of his
humanity and embrace the power inside
him now kylo has experienced some of
this kind of pain but nothing like what
Anakin went through so maybe seeing this
moment is forcing him to ask himself is
this journey to follow in my
grandfather's footsteps worth that kind
of pain or considering the last [ __ ] I
really left kylo in a state of moving on
from his past letting the past die
refusing to let Vader's legacy to find
him maybe this dream is forcing him to
confront the man the Jedi that his
grandfather once was in the last second
before his face was covered with the
mask and that maybe the man behind the
mask is someone worth learning from not
the specter that he'd been worshipping
and trying to live up to
perhaps that past is the history worth
letting die whereas the hidden history
of Anakin Skywalker's humanity is a past
that should live on well what do you
think George hopefully the work my
question for you guys is what other
scenes or characters from the Star Wars
prequels would you like to see reappear
in Star
episode 9 solo gave us that cool cameo
from all I think it's only fair episode
9 includes a mace windu force ghost
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow new rockstars on twitter and
instagram at new rockstars and for my
sometimes off-putting inner thoughts
follow me on twitter and instead of you
talking around about Star Wars stuff and
if you live in the LA area
ya gotta come see my nerdy parody show
infinity fan our first show sold out and
now we're back with a new show new
material new cast members and not-so-bad
kylo Ren impression from me basically
I'm just talking like this and
threatening to take my shirt off nailed
it right it's Friday November 16th at 8
p.m. acne theater North Hollywood
tickets on sale soon it subscribe to
this channel for more deep dives into
everything you love now sure we've been
leaning more toward Marvel lately but
when people say Marvel has replaced Star
Wars as the number one pop culture brand
there is only one response to that
[Music]